got hardware or software over whelmed
that's what we're talking about on
today's video podcast hey there my name
is Cameron and this is the motion
science video podcast I'm so excited to
have you with me here today because we
were talking about hardware / software
overwhelmed and well what does that mean
it's really simple I get asked all the
time what software do I need what
hardware do I need and I feel like a lot
of people get really caught up in those
two aspects of motion design when really
you should be caught up in how to become
better as a motion designer right so we
kind of a lot of the much designers out
there we kind of get stuck in that that
thing of well I can't start being a
better motion designer until I have the
right hardware in place or the hardware
is slowing me down and I can't be a
better motion designer because of that
or vice versa the software I don't have
the right plugins so I can't be the best
motion designer if I only had this
plug-in then I could be really awesome
at motion design well the truth of the
matter is is that neither one of those
are going to stop you from being the
best motion designer you can be they may
be slowed you down a little bit
depending Hardware more than the
software but you don't have to be so
caught up in having that right hardware
and software before you can be the best
motion designer that you can be so what
I would suggest to you is the first
thing you need to do is you need to get
really really clear on what it is that
you want to do now I talked about this
in a lot of my videos you have to be
very clear on what it is you want to do
what fulfills you creatively as artists
we want we don't want to do the work we
that doesn't fulfill so we only want to
do the work that does fulfill us now
someone sometimes
the work that doesn't fulfill us may pay
some of the bills and that's okay
it keeps you know life a little bit more
interesting but ultimately you want to
focus on the work that fulfills you so
you need to get really clear on what
type of work you want to do okay because
that's gonna play in big-time into the
software and even the hardware side of
things so if you're a motion designer
who's really interested in what most of
us a good majority of us are doing
that's 3d software and pretty much After
Effects right now a lot of us can get by
with just using cinema 4d and After
Effects blender is a is a program that's
really moving up in the ranks in my
opinion and a lot of other motion
designers opinion blenders not there yet
though right because there's not the
technical side there's not the there's
not the support side there is the
technical side there's not the support
side for blender so as a creative studio
I'm not gonna come to you and say you
it's okay for you to do all your working
blender because we don't have someone
here at the studio that can take your
files and make revisions and things like
that so blender just isn't high enough
you know in the in the game yet with
motion designers to be a pro application
it's a great application to learn on but
an application like cinema 4d is one
that there's a technical support side
too if I have a problem I can call up
support and say hey we're under a
deadline this isn't working what can we
do to fix this problem right so major
software packages like cinema 4d Maya I
don't know there's a lot of them out
there Houdini
Lightwave they're gonna be more
acceptable if you want to learn the 3d
side of things so if you do want to be a
3d artist you need to look at some of
the mainstream 3d software and once you
get that don't focus on okay and well
now I have to have X
articles or I have to have octane the
renderer just get that package and start
learning everything you can learn about
it right you also need to understand
some basic principles of what makes a
good motion designer which is
understanding motion and animation and
understanding the design side of it so
I've talked about in a previous video
how important it is that we understand
design as well as animation if you
haven't seen that video go check it out
because it's really important that you
understand design as well so once you
get that software like I said just you
know play around and have fun a lot of
times create creative limitations or
what make us create the best work that
we can create so I see like 3d artists
they think they have to get if they're
gonna spend all this money to get cinema
4d all of a sudden they have to also get
a third-party renderer like octane right
and they have to also spend the money on
that and now send they're trying to
learn to software's at the same time
right so just get cinema 4d it's got
some amazing renderers built into it and
just understand the program right I mean
you can also get like a free program
like I said like blender and I start
understanding how you can model and
texture and light things and then some
of that knowledge is going to transfer
to a program like cinema 4d and you can
use it there but don't get so caught up
all night I have to have the best
software I have to have all these
plugins for this 3d package so let's
talk about as a 2d / 3d artists it's
also important that a lot of us know
After Effects so I would say get the
Adobe CC subscription right you're gonna
get that subscription you're always
gonna have the newest version of After
Effects which in my opinion that's a
whole other thing After Effects is
updated every year don't immediately
jump to the newest version okay if it
comes out in the fall I'm gonna wait six
months before I update to the newest
version of After Effects or Photoshop or
illustrator because there's a lot of
bugs typically in that software when it
first comes out that I don't want to
deal with if you're in a middle
a project and let's say you're a
freelancer and you're working on a
project and the new after-effects comes
out or a new plugin inside of After
Effects comes out and you immediately
you're so excited about the new feature
and you you jump on and you you upgrade
it and all of a sudden your project
doesn't work I see it happen all the
time and you're screwed right you're
stuck you don't know what to do because
all of a sudden the project you're in
the middle of doesn't work something
about doesn't work or you have to pass
that project on to the studio that you
that maybe they hired you and they don't
have the newest version of After Effects
well they're gonna be upset with you
because why did you jump and upgrade in
the middle of a project to have the
latest greatest version of After Effects
when you could have just stuck with what
was tried-and-true and got the job done
so
as a motion designer After Effects is
super important you also don't need to
focus on having all these plugins for
After Effects okay it's just like in the
3d world if you're using After Effects
you don't have to have the particle
plugins you don't have to have the
effects plugins the globe plugins the
the animation plugins the scripts all
that there's so many scripts and plugins
available to us today and it's awesome
because it makes our job easier with
depending on what that task is that
we're trying to accomplish but you're
gonna learn more about the process of
motion design by focusing on the core
properties of what you need to get done
the core problem that you're trying to
solve and that that's related to just
motion design in general understanding
how to make amazing motion design and
then the other half of is the software
right so dive in with your project dive
into After Effects and there's so many
plugins inside there you know limit
yourself to what's there and make your
project and you're gonna be you don't
you're gonna be amazed at what you
create and those plugins those are like
the extra like polish on top at the end
of the project my philosophy that I
teach in my high-end memberships like
style craft I'm I also teach it in my
pro flows plus membership is that you
don't always have to have the plug-in to
make it amazing you want to get your
project 80% there you want to have that
solid design base and that solid
animation and you've got this awesome
looking project and then the last 20% of
that project is the effects that you can
layer on top to really polish that
project off and finish that project
you know that's things like glows and
chromatic aberrations and distortions
and blurs and just subtle details but
you don't have to have all these plugins
to do that stuff so determine where you
want to be as a motion designer do you
want to be focused on 2d and or is it
two T's is it motions that design is
that visual effects is that rotoscoping
is a compositing is it more of the 3d
side of things where it's animating a
texturing whatever that is decide where
you want to be creatively what fulfills
you
and then just get a basic package a
basic software package that can help you
fulfill that desire that creative desire
that you have then you need to focus on
it and don't get distracted okay I see
it all the time as well where a motion
designer will get like I said this
package and then they want to add this
plug-in and this plug-in this plug-in
and maybe because it's on sale they're
gonna grab this script don't do that
don't distract yourself give yourself a
set time frame and focus in on what it
is in that software that's gonna help
you get to that better place as a motion
designer okay you don't need to be a
jack-of-all-trades you need to be able
to get in there and and work a piece of
software and know the ins and outs of it
quickly because as you know as most of
you know motion design can be a very
tedious and lengthy process right I see
on socials and and different boards
online that like here's a project I
worked on it took me 80 hours I worked
on it for you know 10 days straight and
here it is and it's 10 seconds long Wow
and it's like that's if it's true though
it takes a lot of time and when you're
adding in these different elements like
different plugins and scripts and
different software's it's going to take
even more time because all of a sudden
you're trying to learn this program and
this program and this program okay so
that's my rant on software now on
hardware I'm not mr. techie I know
enough to be dangerous right and as a 3d
artist I work I work in cinema 4d I
wouldn't call myself a 3d artist I would
call myself a motion designer I'm a
generalist I'm a badass inside of After
Effects and I know enough 3d to be
dangerous okay
and to be dangerous that means that I
can take a 3d model I'm really good at
lighting it animating it
I'm not going to model it I'm not going
to texture it I'm either gonna hire
someone else to do that
or I'm going to work with someone else
who does that or I'm going to buy that
model on a website so for me having a
computer hardware that is tailored to a
3d artist isn't as big a deal okay
I'm an Apple guy I work on Macs if I was
working exclusively with cinema4d
doing high-end renderers I'm gonna have
like the new Mac Pro we're dependent
when you're watching this video it's a
very expensive machine probably not
gonna upgrade or pay the extra money for
that instead I'm plugging to get like an
iMac Pro right with all those CPUs and
the GPUs a GPU is very important if
you're using like a third-party renderer
right then you want this this amazing
GPU plugged into that computer to help
render much faster pcs you have a lot of
different components that you can add to
those machines I would recommend a
really good GPU right if you're 3d now
if you're a 2d artist and you're using
After Effects the biggest important
factors are lots of RAM I'm gonna
personally use at least 64 gigs of ram
on a laptop you know depending what that
is sometimes you're not able to get 64
gigs of ram at least 32 gigs of ram the
machine I'm on right now is an iMac 5k
it's got 64 gigs of ram the next iMac I
buy I'm not getting the pro I'm just
getting an souped-up iMac because I'm
worn in after-effects I'm gonna get at
least 128 gigs of ram okay it's also
really important to have a very fast
clock speed on your CPU and you want to
have that CPU be able to do turbo
boosting to increase a clock speeds
that's gonna help with your rendering
right now unfortunately at this time
After Effects doesn't utilize multiple
CPUs when it comes to rendering but
there are scripts out there now I said
like it's not so important to focus on a
script or a plug-in but in this case a
rendering script that you can buy on
different websites I'm not going to name
them off but a few of them out there
there are scripts that help you take
advantage of all the CPUs that you're
complete
may have to help you render and pieces
inside of After Effects and compile that
those pieces into one render they're
gonna make your renders a lot quicker
but in terms of an After Effects artists
fast CPU lots of RAM right and there are
some other factors as well with with
like having SSD drives and things like
that but like I said you don't need to
get caught up in that I've got an Apple
MacBook Pro from 2014 with 16 gigs of
ram on it that I still work with every
single day in terms of when I'm starting
to build out projects and design
projects as some of you may know I
design in After Effects I don't design
in Photoshop Illustrator I designed
style frames I design all my
compositions inside of After Effects and
that's another video in itself but that
MacBook Pro from 2014 with 16 gigs of
ram is still enough to get me going and
to get me a good part of the way into my
project before I jump onto the iMac here
to start doing Ram previews or retina
previews in general and rendering
elements out and things like that so
that's what I've got for you today if
you've got hardware and software
overwhelmed don't feel like you have to
have the best of the best limit yourself
when you limit yourself you're gonna
find your creatives creativity is going
to skyrocket right my best work comes
out of creative limitations I love it
when a client comes to me and says you
can't use anything external our team
doesn't have it you've got to use the
basic After Effects software and here's
your creative limitations on things like
typefaces you can use colors elements
that's when my best work comes because I
have to really think and be creative and
it just fulfills me okay and I only get
new hardware when my hardware I
currently have is dying or I find that
it's really really slowing down but for
the most part my Apple products last me
for years and years and years before I
upgrade them so if you find value in
this video blog I would invite you to
got motion science TV of God other video
blogs posted there I've got a lot of
courses and powerful memberships like
style craft and pro flows plus pro flows
plus is where it's at
I teach a lot of techniques and
workflows in that membership and it's
very affordable so until next time
thanks for watching this video I'm
Cameron and this is motion science
[Music]